liebes tagebuch heute morgen habe ich
das katzenklo sauber gemacht
max und ich nenne das immer schatzsuche
manchmal findet man auch ganz große
schätze
danach habe ich das vierte tüchern von
meinem adventskalender geöffnet
heute war schokolade drin ich finde
elisas alle braucht einen namen
das war mein outfit of the day
dann bin ich mit max rausgegangen
plötzlich wollte er meinen zuschauern
unser adresse zeigen
das dürfte er aber nicht danach haben
wir den bus zu unserem lamborghini
genommen das ist natürlich nur ein
scherz
dann hatten wir ein richtig leckeres
weihnachtsessen
es gab sogar klöße klöße mit der keule
habe ich dann so getan als ob ich ein
wikinger wäre nach dem essen haben wir
freunde besucht und dann sind wir nach
hause gefahren
ich habe t geschenkt bekommen henry und
thomas haben sich gefreut uns zu sehen
und thomas hat sich in meinen schuh
verliebt ich bin so stark dass ich
thomas mit einer hand festhalten kann
henry ist zu schwer
als ich mit den beiden auf dem teppich
gespielt habe musste ich darüber
nachdenken dass wir später auf den
weihnachtsmarkt gehen und ich das video
ganz schnell schneiden muss weil es
bestimmt noch öfter passieren wird habe
ich beschlossen das tagebuch nicht jeden
tag weiter zu führen
wie oft ich es mache werden wir sehen
aber ich erlebe ja nicht wenn ich immer
nur am video schneiden bin
ende